madame solo goub sur la question des
téléconsultations je veux vraiment
rappeler qu'il s'agit de réguler on
parle d'un pour cent des arrêts maladie
1% des arrêts maladie alors vous dites
justement c'est peu donc est-ce qu'il
faut le réguler ça double chaque année
ça double chaque année alors ça reste
peu mais en dynamique on voit qu'il y a
une croissance très forte la question
qu'on doit se poser c'est à qui est dû
cette croissance
contrairement à ce que j'ai pu entendre
ici ou là c'est pas des habitants de
territoire ruraux qui seraient privés
d'un accès à un médecin généraliste ou
un médecin traitant à 80 ou 90% c'est
des habitants en zone urbaine et un
autre fait qui est intéressant c'est que
pour ces arrêts maladie prescrit en
téléconsultation qui ne viennent pas du
médecin traitant qu'est-ce qu'on
constate
une minorité de ces arrêts maladie donne
lieu à une prescription de médicaments
ou de soins
par rapport à des arrêts maladie
classiques qui eux en grande majorité
donne lieu à des prescriptions de
médicaments ou de soins et donc
objectivement ce qu'on chasse c'est tout
simplement des personnes qui font une
forme de nomadisme numérique jusqu'à
trouver un professionnel de santé qui
acceptera en visioconférence de lui
délivrer un arrêt maladie il y a des
articles qui ont été produits après que
j'ai fait cette annonce j'envoie
notamment un article du Parisien une
journaliste qui attitré son papier
comment je me suis fait prescrire un
arrêt maladie en deux minutes sur
Internet voilà
c'est évidemment pas un phénomène majeur
en termes de volume mais on fait en
termes de dynamique ça double chaque
année depuis deux ans donc moi je
préfère qu'on régule un certain nombre
de choses en amont quand c'est encore
marginal plutôt qu'on se pose la
question des années après en disant vous
avez laissé ce phénomène s'amplifier
vous avez rien fait voilà maintenant ce
qu'on a prévu de faire par ailleurs
c'est des mesures d'accompagnement de
meilleures informations de mobilisation
des plateformes évidemment pour pas que
ça coupe l'accès à des arrêts maladie
pour des personnes qui en ont besoin
mais aujourd'hui dans les bénéficiaires
on constate que c'est pas des personnes
qui sont dans des déserts médicaux et
qui n'arrivent pas à trouver un médecin
c'est plutôt des gens qui se disent que
leur médecin traitant n'acceptera pas de
leur faire un arrêt maladie aussi
facilement qu'il le souhaiterait voilà
je dis des choses caches